what does these statistics who took this
quiz they take this quiz is it cheating
or not is it no that's fine for people
watching at home this is either gonna
bring you guys closer together or make
people break up if your partner flirts
with someone in person one type of flirt
that's fine flirting it's not cheating
but yeah but it's like don't feel yeah I
would say no it's no even though I'd be
pissed yeah I would also say yes for me
it's like what is what's the point
I don't like the weird sad guy in the
corner I want the happy guy that's kind
of funny with everybody's when every
girl's like he's adorable
I'm like I think like for women like
smiling is like uh-huh she was like you
know what if your partner goes for
coffee with someone they're attracted to
you see it's that last part that they're
attracted to why is that bother me so
yeah right it's like if I want to go out
to coffee with Alicia Keys like
obviously I'm attractive easkey whoa
oh I'm yeah she probably would be
jealous you hanging out with Alicia Keys
can I come I'm coming too what if your
partner gives their number to someone
they're attracted to for what yeah for
what that literally happened to me Oh No
at the end of the night he asks for her
number I was like hey we should all hang
out and she gave it to him and I was
just watching the entire thing I was
just like well I just want to see how
this plays out because I am fascinated
right now if it dude asked me for my
number and I gave it to him and I'm like
yeah but I have a man that's say that's
telling him like what are you gonna do
together yeah it should be blue or
cheating yes cheating no if your partner
pretends you guys are just friends when
they run into certain people oh I would
hate that it's not cheating but maybe
you just got to worry if you're in a
relationship period at that point you
know what that makes me feel like is
that you're the other person like
they're married and then it's like this
is my friend taking of my class what I'm
like
if your partner falls asleep in someone
else's bed waitwait sitting in we're
adults you have a home come home there's
ubermann wait call me do you know what I
mean what did you say I don't say
anything do anything once you kind of
take away like the dorm rooms right and
like roommates yeah you're right like
the older you get the harder it is
actually to fall asleep in something
just like find yourself and someone else
is bearable what if your partner
drunkenly kisses someone once there's a
cow is cheating yeah it's cheating for
sure
drunken kissing what are you saying Wow
I'm gonna use that line next time I just
got with someone at a bar it's your
responsibility to figure out as an adult
what you're capable of when you drink
and if the things you do when you drink
are not ideal then it's on you to not
get yourself to that state
it's very mature
[Music]
you